some people have been taking quarantine
time to bake bread and do all this stuff
that I don't do but is it true that
you've been trying out tik tok dances
and I really want to see one here's the
thing like I think that anyone with
children is probably observing them
playing a lot more video games than you
had planned this summer because of the
quarantine and so one of the things that
I've been trying to do is find any way
to engage with them or like connect with
them yeah yes my older son who's 14 has
gotten into I mean he's always on his
power and usually he's scrolling through
tick-tock I don't even know what it was
so I have a youtube channel and so we
did a video that we posted on YouTube of
me basically saying to my kid like what
is tick-tock how do I do it there's a
lot of this motion with them you've got
names for it there's a lot of like no
and it like goes with the song oh my god
I love this I think this challenge for
all parents to have to do I tried to do
one that normanni I can't remember that
it was some kind of day challenges of
basketball involves I had to pop it off
my behind I was like her past it's like
it's very fast and I was like why can't
we do it slow and miles my older son
said cuz you're an old person and so I
asked this only because you're a
neuroscientist in real life
how does dancing actually help our
brains Oh does it yes so um I mean any
movement is good especially for your
mood especially during quarantine that
kind of movement it does it stimulates
serotonin also doing something that's
enjoyable it increases the amount of
happy hormones that are in your brain
and in your body
also things like adrenaline are
important getting your heart moving
because I literally feel like I've been
barefoot for 3 months sitting on my
couch so anytime that I'm doing
something other than like walking to the
fridge or the bathroom it feels like a
real accomplishment and that actually is
it is it's good for your brain it's good
for your physiology and that's one of
the only things especially in like the
heat of the quarantine it's really one
of the only things that we have been
able to do is just move our bodies
sometimes tick-tock dances sometimes
it's vigorous walking ok yeah I'll take
walking and like music or an audio or
audible
listen to book subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my Channel please
don't make me keep going